oh my name is Mary Quigley hello my name
is una Troy we're gonna talk about what
falafel localization
um my name is Noriko si and she is you
know joy we're gonna talk about what
form of a localization so we will
perceives today's talk along this
outline we start from introduction to go
from alpha we discuss our form of alpha
localization project we give overview
challenges and current status and she's
going to talk about localize welcome
alpha features and after that I will
talk about Japanese Wolfram Alpha
I did some demo using Japanese waffa
waffa live site anything I'll summarize
briefly at the end so introduction to
Wolfram Alpha
what is welcome Appa I hope everybody
here knows welcome alpha what is what
welcome are already but just in case
what is welcome alpha so it's a unique
system for computing answers and
providing knowledge we call it
computational knowledge engine so the
goal over from alpha is to make the
worst knowledge computable we released
Wolfram Alpha may choose of 2009 it's
like nine and half years ago and it
studies from is it started from public
website and then the public website is a
I think most popular product from our
part now but it's not just a well it's
not just the website anymore it's way
more than that there are so many welcome
alpha so many products that powered by
alpha Maho technology so here's a warm
alpha mobile and web apps powered by
Wolfram Alpha and will from a puerperal
it has quite strong feature a
step-by-step solutions program
generators like our from alpha power ups
and then there's what form of appliances
and there is
welcome program generators tools and you
can even use what form of Ortonville
from language and there are developer to
develop our products so and then as a
latest welcome multiple that we released
Japanese Wolfram Alpha this year June
this year
so welcome alpha localization project
overview so the goal of ramappa is to
make word knowledge computable the goal
of what form a localization project is
to make computation knowledge more
accessible and useful internationally
this is roughly more than two years
project the project team consists of
translators curator Derek curators
developers testers that language natives
dozens of people are involved to
different degrees and localized waffa
waffa is built on top of the rigor
nglish language Wolfram Alpha and first
release core 1.0 version release goal is
to make almost related features in one
form of a localized to Japanese Spanish
and Chinese and Korean French and
Russian for the input localized future
can be queried in both the localized
language and English the rest feature
can still be curried normally in English
to the output features fully localized
will generally show a completely
localized output others may show up as a
mixture of localization language and
English for the current state thus
current status is how we just released
Japanese warm alpha version 1.0 June
this year and then Chinese and Spanish
will be the next and then the Korean for
integration will read after that and
what exactly we have been working them
we have of course we have lots of lots
of huge amount of data and linguistic
patterns and
to requite but it's not just a
translation it's way more than that we
have lots of lots of language specific
issues to resolve
for example word variations some
languages have infractions like pull ll
singers but the others don't and like
French they have a grammatical genders
but the other language don't have such
thing and like in grammatical cases some
languages has nominative accusative
genitive dative and like how Chinese
Korean and Japanese have fondarific form
but the others don't have such thing and
some luggage have classify your major
counter words and like English
differently indeed they have in definite
indefinite articles but the others own
and of course sentence structures are
different and then ordering of past
parts of different and then partitioning
sentence of difference so like English
French Russian they have they use space
between words but Chinese Japanese and
Korean they don't use space between
words so and even math operator can have
different meeting meaning each language
for example like tilde is used for
vodiane not operator but it is used to
use us to when it's used in between
numbers in Korean Japanese and the other
thing is comma comma could be decimal
point oh this is sweet or just simply
come one so there is ambiguity between
one comma two three four and then one
point two three four
she's know she's going to talk about
this later about this data so it's not
just I'll translate from translate from
English to other language but we have to
think about special handling and special
holistic - for the special each specific
issue for the specific language
Thank You Erica for giving us an
overview of our project so in the next
few minutes I'm going to give you a
little demonstration of different
features in the localized versions so
these features are these pictures are
really what creates an amazing user
experience for user experience for users
in the other countries so of course as
they could look at how different input
language affect the output so here I'm
showing you English version in Korean
version and I typed integrate 1 over X
from 1 to 2 in my mind of language
Korean and WolframAlpha it's actually
giving us two kinds of output one is
mathematical output so the equation and
the plots this stays the same across
languages however for however for like
language texts so the the things
highlighting the Reds are presented in
the local language so the button box and
the path title and the gray text which
associated with the math contents will
help to guide you in your native
language so these pictures are these
features make output easier to
comprehend and another thing worth
mentioning is that localizable from
Alpha understands two languages English
and language of the localized version so
when typed in either language English or
you're in your or your native language
then output is given in the target
language so you can switch it is it is
possible because Wolfram Alpha locos
Wolfram Alpha is actually built on top
of the English version so you can switch
the language you put in as an input and
you get the same output in the localize
language and not only you can type not
only can you type the language in either
not only can you type the input in
language but also you can type in you
can type the same question in multiple
different ways and you still get the
same output so in every culture in every
language things do not always translate
one-to-one so I'm gonna talk about
different defaults unit system and
localize date format localize localized
number from it and there's no Supriya as
an example so localize WolframAlpha use
a different default unit system
depending on variety of vectors this
includes the language of localized
version itself and the IP address of a
user so I typed in distance from Paris
to Champaign as an input and into in the
English version and Korean version and I
sent my location as if I'm in Champaign
and Seoul so because USA is one of the
three countries that have not adopted
our metric system as you can see on the
output for the English version in
Champaign the your output is given in
imperial system but the rest of tho but
as you can see in the rest of the output
is given in SI system so that user does
not have to convert their units but they
can choose to convert convert it
manually in the preference tab another
important aspect of translation is they
permit so each country use a different
date format in China in China in Japan
and Korea use year-month-day format but
in Spain France Russia uses a month year
format
and also each country use either 12 hour
time format or 24 hour time format and
in China and Korea we use 12 hour format
and so he indicates evening and morning
however for the rest of the country
Japan Spain France and Russia uses 24
hour format so um this is supported
because local users local users have a
best experience when they feel like when
they feel that the product has been
developed just for them so and I'm gonna
talk about the number format for the
next so before we get into the number
for men which number will be more
familiar to English speaker it would be
the left one right the 45 points 86
million but for Chinese Japanese like
China Chinese Japanese Korean speaker
actually the 4586 10000 it's more easier
to read and it is because the mystery
languages have a different number system
so let's take a look at this unclear
so each language have a different number
format that they use for example in
English there's a name for ten to the
six which is million and ten to the nine
which is billion
however for Korean Japanese Chinese
language there's no name for this tool
to name two numbers but instead there's
a name for ten thousand and 100 million
and another reason why using correct
name is important is because there might
be there may be a same name representing
two different numbers so for instance if
you look at the English a billion that
represents
six but in Spanish and French version in
French Spanish and French language or
any other European language actually use
billion to represent 10 to the 12 so for
this reason in the English and Korean
version or other localized version Apple
is given in the number format de using
the local so these three numbers are
actually the same number but with a
different representation and if you take
a look at the English and the Russian
version use 45 point 86 so English
version uses that as a decimal separator
and in Russian version they use a comma
as a decimal separator so that's what
I'm going to talk about the next slides
so our bodies used as a decimal
separator in China and Japan in Korea
but oh combines also use commas used as
a decimal separator in Spain Russia and
France and we also support the input for
decimal separator so if you take a look
at this on something I typed in to
integrate 1 over x from 1.2 to 1.4 so in
the output in the mathematical
expression we can use you can see the
comma is used instead of not as a
decimal separator but actually it's not
on this slide but if you actually type
in integrate 1 over X from 1 comma 2 to
1 comma 4 then all for now for quickly
interpret 1 comma 2 as a number instead
of a list of a number so in Spanish and
French version comma can be used as a
decimal separator in the world falafel
and I'm first
and the last thing I want to talk about
is a new compact sets all of it
available only in Korean and Japanese
language so we know in each country math
curriculum the older which student learn
the concepts are slightly different and
in Korea and Japan education system is
centered around the college entrance
exams so we actually have arranged the
example why because I'm posed in a
cordon in accordance with their school
Huracan system so that user can find
examples easily by the topic there's no
in there taught in school so Noriko will
later talk about more about the Japanese
curriculum base layout and when there's
a lot more interesting things to talk
about but I will undo all that America
so now about Japanese welcome alpha so
Japanese welcome alpha first version was
released June this year the whole design
is the same as English original Wolfram
Alpha website there's an input form
window here and then there are the links
to example queries down here the
categories we localized already are
written in Japanese like here and then
these these are the categories we
haven't localized yet those are written
in English and then so this is a mask
categories and then this is the one the
uno was mentioning that is a high school
math category that so in here you can
find a lot of example queries that we
collected from the university entrance
exams or university other nation one
university admission tests we call
national center tests for university
admission so we collected those tests
in the past and then put them into
subcategories based on math high school
math curriculum in Japan like muslin or
musty must you must be three so looking
through these examples it's quite
powerful high schooler middle schoolers
they can easily get feel of what they
should ask or how they should how they
can ask and let's take a look at some
demo so first example is to find
integration in tickly it's all very
tightly so integrate song X from X X
equal Delta Pi then this is like
Japanese website ok anyway so you get
answered and then you get the
visualization for the integral and then
you can even get Riemann sum summation
and then you get the indefinite integral
you can sell step-by-step solutions I'll
also localize the into Japanese so you
if you click here yeah you can get the
step by solution in Japanese like step 1
calculate the different integral and
step 2 apply the fundamental theorem of
calculus the antiderivative of sine X is
minus cosine X and then get evaluate the
antiderivative at limit and subtract and
get the answer to so this is quite
simple like 3 step step by step but
let's take a look at the next example so
hope free I walked
so uh - yeah yeah yeah this is an
example for solving in creation the
answer is X equal one and y equal two
and then you got a plot for that and you
can get the step a solution for that too
okay so there are actually multiple ways
to solve equation maybe the most typical
way is by elimination but there are
three other way like substitution or
Gaussian elimination and then there is a
least popular method maybe kalmo's
method calomel Kalmar so sure let's take
a look at the step by step solution with
by kalmo's rule so so in step two
Express the system in matrix form and
then solve the system with commas rule
and then evaluate the determinant and
then cancel terms and simplify and then
you get an answer here so you can even
get the intermediate step by step like
how to get determinant for this one if
you click that you can get set basis for
that okay and then the last example is
for finding in friction points this is
what we supported this is just a
positive solution we supported recently
in English but it's localized already
but it's not online it's a it's
accessible by just testify but let's
take a look so there are so many steps
you get to get that in friction point
but briefly like you have you have to
compute first derivative and then you
have to compute a second derivative
as a steps yes and then find where the
second derivative is zero by solving 6x
minus 6 equals 0 and then classify you
have to classify concavity
so the 4 minus 4 the range minus
infinity to 1 it's concave down and then
for the range 1 to infinity it's concave
up then find where the points of
instructional curve then get the answer
so you can get those step-by-step
solution and vocalize language okay so
the future work of course we have to
continue to improve the support for
maths area we have to want to we need to
minimize the rate that we warm up I
cannot give you any answers and the
output we have to localize all the parts
of the output and of course we have to
expand support area to outside of mass
we have lots of those beautiful area in
Ohama also we have to look rise that and
as a future challenge so we have we are
thinking of we have to think about you
improve accessibility from mobile
devices this is very important for
Japanese because Japanese spent one hour
two hours maybe three hours every day on
public transportation to go to school to
go to office and then they're using
mobile phone smartphone mobile devices
to kill their time student even study on
trains buses so we have to think about
Japanese users that want to use formal
phone mobile devices so it's very
important that they can put their query
on their mobile device easily or the
output will be clear and including up on
the mobile devices and the next one is
we have a lots of lot of
nice data city rider school data Friday
later lots of those of their useful data
but those are not all but most of the us
centralized so we have to localize data
itself it's so we have to think about
how to get those data or how to how to
curate those data it's gonna be a big
challenge for us so summary it's just a
brief summary we we talk about localized
waffa waffa and japanese waffa waffa
released june this year and five more
language will be coming soon hope free
and then we we will continue until the
mouth area supporting expand supported
area
thank you
[Applause]